you did one of my favorite videos on
Saturday Night Live one of my favorite
Impressions I did you roll
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it Welcome To Deal or No
Deal I'm hoe Mandel by picking one case
you can go home with one cent or $1
million one Banker one button and just
one question Deal or No Deal Deal I love
that you know I called you right after
that do you remember that I phoned you
that next morning oh you did i ph that's
the first time I actually spoke to you
and that's when I I met you and it was
so funny and so good and you really
captured my the essence of what just
very it was like presentational well you
know uh not to make this about me at all
but that's exactly what it what what
happened was that show was really hard
for me because I innately want people to
do well yeah you know and um being face
Toof face with somebody who is making
ridiculously stupid decisions that's
tough you know it really is cuz you know
a person would come on and tell me they
have three kids no health insurance
they've never owned a home they got $5
in the bank and I'd go and you know the
first offer is $20,000 and you live in
Omaha someplace that's a down payment on
a house that's a more than you're making
for the year and they go no deal and
they would just show right and that's
really hard for me it was good for the
game and for the show I guess so what
happened was and I had all this stuff
planned where I was going to be really
funny I didn't want to do a game
show and then when I realized that they
were doing this I started talking to
them like I talked to my kids when they
were five because I wanted them to focus
and hear me yeah and I'd go the offer
is 20
20,000 yeah
$20,000 this is a lot of money yeah but
it but what was so funny is to watch you
take what I was trying to do and I went
it just hit me so hard it was so
wonderful that you picked up
on what in my mind didn't I didn't
realize it was so out there but I was so
overthe toop presentational it was so
funny and so
I cried watching it and the fingers and
the and the the hand movements and
everything it was my favorite moment of
watching SNL just because I just I was
incredibly honored you know and I
thought you did such a good job but I
thought the essence of what would make
it like if somebody told me they were
going to do me from Deal or No Deal I go
why is that even funny like I didn't see
it you know and then when I saw you I
went number one this is hysterical and
number two he's just when you on
Saturday Night Live when they say okay
they're going to do a Deal or No Deal
sketch yeah is it um and and you're
going to play a real character whether
it's me or anybody else what do you do
do you sit and watch tapes of the how do
you or do you come to them to say or do
you come no this one I think was the
opposite where they just asked like can
you do Howe and I was like yeah I think
I can do it and then I tried to do like
sense memory like I try to remember I'm
like he's kind of like and as I start
saying he's kind of like it starts sort
of happening or not happening if it's
someone who I can't do I got to say like
no let's maybe ask you know Bill or
[Music]
somebody